und jetzt nehmen wir mal die zeit und
sagen anständig herzlichen glückwunsch
lieber im manuell makro dem frechen
franzosen wurde gestern in aachen der
orden wider den tierischen ernst
verliehen
der karlspreis ist ja noch lustiger und
zwar ausdrücklich für makros europa
vision erste gratulantin eine frau in
einem lachsfarbenen kostüm
die ihre letzte europa vision irgendwann
in den achtzigern hatte und da war sie
garantiert besoffen der makro wird von
uns mit preisen und komplimenten
regelrecht zugeballert damit er nicht
merkt dass wir auf keinen seiner europa
vorschläge eingehen der arme mann achtet
immer darauf der arme mann ist nach
einem jahr im amt inzwischen völlig
ausgemergelt das muss man so sagen
jeden lebensmut verloren
dabei hat doch alles so wunderbar
angefangen zwischen diesen beiden wir
haben ja das schöne wort von hermann
hesse allem anfang wohnt ein zauber inne
hat sich das damals zitierte wusste ich
noch nicht ganz genau dass die bildung
einer regierung so lange dauert deshalb
haben wir den zauber ein bisschen
konserviert und ein paar monate decke
liegt wie romantisch ja man könnte auch
sagen sie hat den zauber weg getobt und
eingefroren es ist wäre die passende
analogie
makro wollte eine neugründung der eu
nicht weniger als eine neugründung der
europäischen union mit eigenem haushalt
eu-finanzminister und europäischer
eingreiftruppe gekriegt hat eine
handvoll nichts
wie enttäuscht sind sie von angela
merkel nein keineswegs
ich warte auf vorschläge da kannst du
lange warten gerade diese woche meine
damen und herren
diese woche mit schwamm beweis doch wir
brauchen dringend mehr europa trotzdem
hat marco seine hoffnung auf deutschland
fast komplett begraben muss man so hart
sagen traurig es ist traurig da kommt
nix mehr
egal was er mutter erzählt egal wie
recht er hat kennst du das auch neben
dir haben viele junge franzosen ständig
neue ideen für europa und du hast echt
keinen bock mehr auf das gelage dagegen
jetzt den noise cancelling kopfhörer von
sony
[Musik]
ampnet jri gelaber um bis zu 80 dezibel
funktioniert auch bei seehofer
echt hässlich
es ist ja so es ist also alles was aus
deutschland noch kommt ist reine europa
rhetorik phrasen und heiße luft oder
noch schlimmer populistisches kassenwart
gerede der faule syrien will an unser
geld wie so eine schallplatte weil er
die nadel hängen geblieben ist
initiativen schon aber wenn initiativen
immer nur dadurch enden dass dort schon
alles bezahlt da gibt's schon sehr viele
menschen in deutschland seien also wir
sind sehr für europa aber dass wir immer
alles bezahlen müssen allein müssen wir
doch gar nicht schon gar nicht allein
diese fixierung aufs deutsches geld
beschützen ist er verschwunden fetisch
krankhaft ist das wirklich ist pervers
wir sind mit abstand mit abstand der
größte profiteur dieser eu im märz 2016
ein beispiel 2016 lag deutschlands
anteil am leistungsbilanzüberschuss der
eu bei 84 prozent
und natürlich wollen wir auch in zukunft
an europa nehmen sich alle anderen
ländern bei uns verschulden während wir
ihnen gleichzeitig vorträge über spahn
halten ja es muss man zugeben
deutschland hat bezogen auf europa schon
diese latente kolonialherren attitüde
wenn ein deutscher finanzminister mehr
zu sagen in europa ist ist okay aber
nicht dass ein europäischer
finanzminister möglicherweise koppeln
haus oder den bayern bestimmt ja
bestimmt doch neben deutschen die
woanders bestimmen das hat der welt noch
nie geschadet aber umgekehrt
brandgefährlich brandgefährlich unsere
europa vision beschränken sich
ausschließlich aufs thema geld die
engländer gehen raus und wir müssen es
bezahlen wo spart man das jetzt ein was
sagt der zuständige eu-kommissar
motorrad katzen chorischen
so aber structural instanz katzen
kabarettprogramm
[Applaus]
bin gerade verwirrt was sind denn das
musical cats natürlich
ein fehler mein fehler das musical cats
immerhin hat unsere groko in dieser
woche einen bürgerdialog zum thema
europa gestartet unter der überschrift
sprechen wir über europa wird er glaube
ich über europa gesprochen
bis herbst tingelt dazu das komplette
kabinett durch die lande und fragt uns
bürgern nach unseren intimsten europa
wünschen
nebenbei gibt es dazu natürlich auch
noch eine hippe online-kampagne betreut
vom cdu hipster albrecht um meine damen
und herren
albrecht die groko sprich europa warum
eigentlich was soll die aktion also wie
erkläre ich das jetzt einem mann der
seine whatsapp nachrichten noch per fax
schickt die frage ich habe einen
zeitplan
die frage war warum ja sorry politik
wird eben nicht mehr von oben verkündet
ist wenn die eltern baby der bürger also
die target group die wird permanent
eingebunden da fragt man die bürger was
geht die vierzehnte ich was können wir
tun
deswegen ist es so wichtig zu wissen was
bedeutet europa für sie persönlich was
ist ihnen wichtig was können wir besser
machen
hat sie das hammer brother habe ich hier
geschrieben der text was können wir
besser machen will hat sie einfach so
raus so text wir sind schon geil aber
was können wir noch besser machen noch
nisa
die marke ist wirklich die queen of an
getäuschte bürgerbeteiligung weiß es
weil sie es drauf weil sie die soft
skills hat verstehst du nein
aber was mir gerade einfällt es gab doch
2015 schon einen großen bürgerdialog zum
thema deutschland ja klar aber da ging
es ja um völlig andere sachen die dialog
aufrufe von 2015 und 2018
die kann man ja gar nicht vergleichen
was ist für sie wichtig im leben was ist
ihnen wichtig darüber möchten wir in
meine kolleginnen und kollegen aus der
bundesregierung mit ihnen sprechen ich
lade sie herzlich ein sich daran zu
beteiligen oder sie können an den
bürgerdialog veranstaltungen teilnehmen
ich freue mich auf sie
ja
inhaltlich gibt es parallelen aber sie
hat ja zwei völlig unterschiedliche
hosenanzüge dann also ehrlich gesagt
machen wir den quatsch alle ein zwei
jahre
damit wir wissen was der bürger gerne
hört und wenn wir dann wahlkampf haben
dann sagen wir den bürgern what was er
gerne hört jetzt wo sie sagen 2012 gab
es auch einen bürgerdialog und umgesetzt
wird nie was doch 2012 wurden
zehntausende vorschläge eingereicht und
davon haben wir umgesetzt insgesamt zwei
momente ich guck nochmal 2
und zwar wurden 100 eichen zum maurer
jubiläum gepflanzt und sex mit tieren
ist seitdem verboten
ja kein witz dürfen sie nicht mehr
jetzt gucken sie nicht so traurig ich
kann ziemlich einnahmen
[Applaus]
es ist kein herz
diese
immer jetzt kapiert dass erst nächstes
jahr ist europawahl
deswegen schon wieder dialogisches ihr
sammelt ideen für ihren wahlkampf exakt
amondo im wahlkampf braucht der deutsche
dieses warme gefühl dass man sich für
seine unfassbar langweiligen geschichten
interessiert wie in einer guten ehe auch
und deswegen stellen die jetzt in allen
großstädten so genannte ultimaten auf da
geht der bürger rein und kann der chefin
mal so richtig sein herz aus verbundes
ganze ich finde ich richtig dass die
groko ihre klimaziele 2020 auf gibt auch
in anderer sache
unser nachbar darstellt eine biotonne
immer so nah an unserem grundstück wenn
du dafür da mal bei den anrufen könnten
natürlich wisse werfen viel geld nach
geld
und und
wir haben das auch mit alexander
dobrindt automaten versucht aber die
wenn immer kaputt gestand natürlich wie
wäre es denn zur abwechslung mal mit
echter bürgerbeteiligung damit sich
etwas ändert
also sie haben das prinzip er immer noch
nicht verstanden oder ich freue mich auf
ihre anregung und ihre vorschläge in
deutschland soll so bleiben wie es ist
ist das jetzt klar geworden leider ja
[Applaus]